Why do you guys aim to become performers? Of course, it's to become a strong man like this
How far can you go?
It's not like I
hate ninjas, so
I'm aiming to be Hokage.  I'm going to become a ninja and be recognized by everyone
This is fine
[Music]
I'm not going to become a ninja,
I'm going to take over my family's temple after I graduate
I thought it would be good to have more work than that, so
[music]
I can shoot properly.
However, there are a lot of children with strong personalities.I wondered what happened
this year,
surprisingly everyone was thinking about
it.The students also said that in the future, they won't become ninjas.
I thought you were going to become a ninja Come to think of it, why
did you enter the academy
?
- If
you do something, I wonder if anyone can see that
I
'm the one who climbs the ladder So, it's time for me to call you a frog.